have you been trying different diets but
are not getting the results you desire
well dr nash has the answer she's been
transforming lives across the valley
take a look at dominic's incredible
results
working with dr nash i lost 70 pounds in
three and a half months and reversed my
type 2 diabetes and i feel
great wow dominic's story
is unbelievable dr nash's transformation
it's amazing so so tell me more about
about dominic and dominic's journey
yeah so dominic was a guy that found out
that he was
pre-diabetic right the foreshadowing of
diabetes
and he found out when he was only 20
years old which is more and more common
these days he was a young man
five years on his own or with his
doctors trying to control
it he ends up being full-blown diabetic
by the age of 25
that's when he drew the line in the sand
he said i don't want to go down this
path
when he came to me not only were we able
to get him to lose
a hundred pounds but he was able to
reverse his type 2 diabetes in
three and a half months it is
unbelievable his success story and like
you said a hundred pounds
so how is it that you can potentially
reverse diabetes how do you do it
yeah so this is something that i found
out through trial and error on my own
that for
many of us especially for struggling
with a condition like pre-diabetes or
type 2 diabetes
we've got damage inside the body that's
actually causing the weight problem
and it's not as simple as you need to
eat less than you need to move more for
people like us it just doesn't work
same thing with dominic he tried eating
less than moving water reverses diabetes
it didn't work so when we found out that
he had hormone damage he had fatty liver
and he had inflammation
we went after that his diabetes reversed
and he lost all the weight
talk to me about the the five metabolic
factors what are we talking about here
yeah so what is that damage that's under
the surface that's driving the weight
problem or the disease well it could be
that your body has a toxicity issue this
is usually associated
with fatty liver there's just too much
toxin in the body the other one is when
we're over fed or undernourished this
means we're getting enough calories
but we're not getting enough nutrition
to repair the body the other one is
retraining the hypothalamus or the set
point where your body honestly believes
it's supposed to sit at a higher weight
than it should
the acidity is a that's where we're
going after inflammation which
rapidly causes weight gain to the belly
and then seven
low or imbalanced hormones that are like
a light switch if they're in the wrong
position
you're not burning body fat even when
you eat less and move more all right dr
nash in about 30 seconds i can talk to
you all day long two quick questions are
these results
typical they're absolutely typical if
you do what i say
they are not typical if you do your own
thing easy enough
and then you you always come to the
table with a special what do you have
for our viewers this week
i do so normally to do the evaluation to
find out if you have a problem
we would normally charge 97 for that
evaluation but if people mentioned that
they saw me with jc on las vegas now
or better yet go to the website that las
vegas now is flashing on the screen
we've already reserved 10 spots 90
percent off it's less than 10 dollars to
find out if i can help you
if you can get it corrected and if you
can get it corrected for good dr nash
you're changing lives i love it thank
you so much for joining us we appreciate
it
you bet thank you so much jc always fun
to be here